foreign
[Music]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five beware
we love you
so much
we're going to tell you the truth Wyatt
is with us Wyatt is in North Dakota hey
Wyatt what's up
I'm good how are you doing better than
we deserve how can we help
so my old lady and I are talking about
getting married how old are you
I am 28. oh she's so how ancient is This
Woman This Old Lady
uh she's only 25. oh she's ancient
she doesn't know that he called her the
old lady telling you we were thinking
about getting married until Wyatt got on
the Ramsey Show and called me an old
lady okay anyway
so we're thinking about getting married
um we're up here in North Dakota working
in the oil fields making pretty decent
money we'd like to kind of simplify
things and combine our income to be able
to pay off debt quicker
um I had talked to her about just going
down to the courthouse quick getting it
done and then later on after we're
completely debt free
saving up and having a big ceremony as
big as she wants it and everything but I
can't quite convince her you sound just
like I could die
he's so romantic you're such a guy
she more wants to go she's all for like
like paying off debt well what's the
difference on like a small vacation oh
okay look I for me
I like you know if somebody says Hey I
want to delay the big expensive party
until later and for now courthouse uh
eloping whatever I just want to make
sure you're doing it because you want to
get married not because you want to pay
off debt faster like I feel like there's
a little bit of motivation and behind
that in my guess is that's maybe the
part that doesn't sound as romantic for
her if you're if you're putting it to
her and serving it up on the platter of
hey honey we can pay off our debt faster
if we just go down to the courthouse and
get the paper as opposed to I want to
marry you today I don't want to wait and
save up money I'm ready to put a ring on
your finger today like that feels
different so maybe just frame it up a
little differently for her yeah okay
yeah yeah
I wanted to do it as cheap as possible
yeah okay so what do you guys make
odd combined 240. good Lord okay and how
much debt do you have
about 205 combined okay
and so you're in North Dakota so you hop
a jet for the weekend
and have a nice weekend in Vegas
and spend
three or four thousand dollars
out of 200 out of 240.
and this is the first time in your
marriage you will learn the lesson happy
wife happy life
okay but please don't say to your wife I
want to get married as cheap as possible
like let that keep that in your heart
yeah that's that's good that's good lady
advice for you there Wyatt okay so yeah
yeah you can't make it sound like a
business transaction and go hey let's
let's do this and we'll have a big party
next year too but spend a couple of
grand you know three three grand and buy
you some airline tickets a nice place
and go to Vegas or go to whatever's ham
think of what's handy to North Dakota
okay yeah but I mean pick you out a spot
and uh you guys go to Yellowstone I
don't care whatever it is but get you
know make it a nice
weekend that's a notch above the
courthouse but still 15 notches below
the expensive wedding
awesome I appreciate it yeah and just um
yeah I appreciate what you're trying to
accomplish mathematically but uh you got
to play the long ball okay you can't
just play short term yeah it makes sense
long term you're gonna tell the story
for the rest of your life right and it
needs to be a better story than the one
you brought to us don't let Elvis do
that don't let Elvis be the officiator
you don't want the Elvis wedding come on
not me I'm not the one I
oh Christopher is with us Christopher is
in Charleston South Carolina hi
Christopher how are you
sure you're doing well Mr Ramsey how
about yourself better than we deserve
what's up
well sir I'm moving to Oklahoma my
family's moving into we're downsizing a
little bit to a less expensive home and
uh so basically when all is said and
done after we sell the house in
Charleston we'll have just enough money
to pay off the house in Oklahoma
completely wow that's awesome our
emergency fund that's awesome which is
great thank you sir yeah we're really
excited I'm on baby step number six so
this could be could be a really big
moment for us thing is uh I'm a I'm a
husband and a father of two we're
looking to expand our family we are
going to need to buy a minivan and then
we also do need to do some Renovations
on the house so is it worth it so my
question for you is should I just throw
all my money at the house get it totally
paid off and then figure out the the car
and the Renault later or should I
figure that stuff out first and accept
an outstanding mortgage on the house wow
um what how extensive a renovation are
we doing are you moving her into some
kind of shanty
no sir not at all not at all they're
thinking they're wrapping up uh in
inspection this afternoon we probably
will need to replace some flooring
um there's a couple other things we want
to do but I'd say probably probably
about ten thousand dollars and what's
your household income going to be in
Oklahoma
100K actually probably closer to 95.
okay and what do you need to spend on
the minivan
well well they're pretty expensive right
now I'm thinking to get something that's
not going to break down all the time
that's going to meet our needs I would
think about 30
yeah there's lots of 20 that don't break
down all the time
okay this thing will break down all the
times kind of an exaggeration they all
break down even the new ones but you
know you know there's lots of wonderful
20 000 events okay so uh and you have
two kids currently and the third is not
on the way yet
not on the way yet that you know of okay
all right yeah
and so yeah so I'm paying off the house
I'm gonna do the renovation then I'm
gonna move up in Van that's what I do
all with cash
I mean because you're gonna roll this
Equity from the previous home into this
home I mean you're not gonna have any
payments you're going to be able to
in the world your baby step seven
yeah you'll stack up that cash in no
time
okay yeah because your house what's your
house payment now
it's fifteen hundred dollars a month so
two grand a month is not even a stretch
yeah three grand four grand a month
you're not even stretch so in three
months two months you've got enough
money to do the renovation
Toca right
yes sir you know what you haven't what's
hard to do until you actually let you
your brain knows you're going to have a
paid off house but your emotions haven't
reminded you to put that into the
formula because with no house payments
dude it's amazing what I can cash flow
okay that's what you're not used to
doing because you've never been there
before so way to go how old are you
way to go way to go I'm proud of you
that's great they might decide they want
to do something nicer with the upgrade
because they have money and they can
just keep saving quickly now there's
that huh
wow very cool love it love it love it
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
welcome to the Ramsay show I'm your host
Dave Ramsey Jade warshaw Ramsey
personality is my co-host today thanks
for hanging out with us hey if you guys
want to help us we could use your help
if you want to help us promote the show
uh that would be a big deal to us we
would appreciate it you are our only
marketing budget so um if you share the
show by clicking share or you know if
you subscribe to the show or follow the
show depending on whether your YouTube
podcast whether you're on if you're
listening on talk radio tell people
about the show that's sharing the show
if you're watching on TBN tell people
you're doing that wherever you're
consuming the show tell people about it
review it give us a five star review if
that particular format allows for
reviews and share it with a friend and
subscribe and follow do all of those
things all of those help us push the
show out with the internet algorithms
into people's face and let them know
we're here and it's one of the reasons
that we're one of the top 10 15 those uh
for instance podcasts in the world on
Apple podcast we're in the top handful
one of the few that have had over a
billion downloads there's only about
five or six of us that have had that so
and you guys are the reason so thank you
thank you we appreciate all the help all
right Brandon is next he's in Columbus
Ohio hi Brandon welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
hey I uh own a own and operate a
business renovating homes and my wife is
a wedding photographer and we just have
some irregular income
um and we are sitting down at the
beginning of the months and planning out
every single dollar but it just seems
like you know we'll get week two or week
three into the month and bills start
coming out and it almost seems like we
run out of money uh at the time the
bills come out and so we sit down and
our budget hits zero but at the same
time it's like when when certain bills
come out we it seems like we kind of ran
out so just wondering what the best way
to do with that is it sounds like you
don't have any money or your planning
sucks paycheck planning
I mean yeah you ought to know those
bills are going to come out when you sit
down at the beginning of the month right
yeah for sure yeah I think so I think uh
it's just a matter of like week two we
get a certain amount of money week three
we get no money that kind of thing so so
the problem is you guys are looking at
the hole you're going okay for this
month we're gonna make five thousand
dollars but you're not considering and
we get paid on the 10th we get paid on
the 13th we get paid on the 17th we get
paid on the 29th so what you've got to
do is and by the way if you don't have
every dollar now's the time for you to
get that because inside of every dollar
you can plan out your paycheck so you
can basically go in right you've already
listed all of your expenses but then you
can go in and say and not only do I have
it listed and it's budgeted for but this
is the date that it goes out and this is
the date that this one goes out and it
will tell you hey that's not going to
work if you do that you're going to run
out of money if you do it in that order
you're going to overdraw so it helps you
kind of Stack these things in the right
order so that you're planning when
you're actually going to spend the money
and that's the piece to this that a lot
of people are missing they put all the
expenses in there but they don't
actually sit down and plan
how and when those are going to come out
and if that actually will work does that
make sense yeah that makes total sense
every every dollar is the world's best
budgeting app we produce it and run it
and it's called the function that she's
talking about it's called paycheck
planning it's in the every dollar app
and so it's free if you want to try it
for free there's an upgrade that
includes connection to your bank that
automatically loads the debit card
charges into your particular categories
and so you go okay here's a grocery
store charge that showed up on my debit
card I just grab it and drag it over
into groceries and it keeps up my food
budget right so it makes it very easy to
work with your spouse and the budget now
do you have enough money coming in each
month to pay the bills and it's just
landing on the wrong dates is that's
what's happening
yeah exactly yeah it's hard because
sometimes it's front loaded sometimes
it's backloaded um just a matter of when
we're giving those payments but yeah
yeah I mean we're paying ourselves like
or we're you know budgeting for the same
about the same amount of months it's
just a matter of when we get about six
thousand okay cool well the other thing
you can do is get a thousand ahead and
just we can leave a thousand leave a
thousand laying there that you don't
touch
and that's just your your slush so a
little 200 item hitting on the wrong
week doesn't blow you up yeah that'll
help smooth it out as well Sharon and I
did that because we ran every we ran
with irregular income for what we have
for our whole lives but it was extremely
volatile when we first started this we
would make nothing literally zero in a
month and then I was doing real estate
deals and we might make 20 000 bucks or
something the next yeah so
um yeah that was that was how we started
wasn't it was completely volatile but we
were making good money annually yeah I
think those two questions that you and
Brandon hit on are the two biggest uh
pain points that people have a hard time
realizing oh that's the problem because
they're like I'm doing my budget what's
going on you know I I listed all the
expenses but if you don't do that
critical step of planning that paycheck
and planning when those items are going
to come out and have that like which you
call that cushion I always call it just
the cushion line item amount you can't
set it to zero like zero baseball
budgeting doesn't mean you have zero
it's not zero but it's not zero based
checking account yeah balance yes it's
zero it's I'm gonna spend all of this
month's income on some category that's
right it doesn't mean you keep a zero
that's right a checking account but it
is zero-based budgeting you do spend
every dollar this month right that is
coming in on something but no it can be
it can be charity it can be whatever
you're doing it could be your tithe
Church it can be whatever you're doing
there but you spend every dollar and and
then the thing that makes it Go fastest
is when you find money by doing that
because as soon as you start doing a
budget you'll feel like you've got to
raise that's right and when you find
money and they're doing that for the
first time you're going to kind of have
this aha moment because most people
budget is real intimidating and when you
finally start doing it and you're making
it behave instead of if you're being
intimidated by it yes then it opens up a
whole new world and then you start
working the baby steps with what you
find the found money gives you the
ability to accelerate through the baby
steps and inside of every dollar we hope
you do that too and that's the financial
roadmap that's right yes and then of
course you know you put real gas on it
by going through Financial Peace
University yes while you're doing all
this and now man now we got this is like
the sub sandwich with every kind of meat
on it here that's right okay this is
like the big mama jama this is it we're
gonna get her done okay and look that's
when it opens up Paul is in New York hey
Paul how are you
I'm good how are you Dave better than I
deserve how can we help
so I find myself in a very peculiar
financial situation
um to kind of give you the rundown uh
and I I had a job in Tech that I'm going
to force you with a tech layoffs this
year
um recently got laid off um I was making
uh 150 days Plus benefits
um additionally I do have a car loan I
do have some student loans which I know
are coming back online soon and then as
well as a personal loan um thankfully I
how much are your student loans
oh um about 20. and how much is your car
loan
uh the remaining principal is twenty
eight five I believe and what's the
personal loan how much uh uh 20 22.5
okay and and now you're unemployed
yes thank you but I do have no credit
card debt I've always treated my credit
card there's charge cards so I never
carry a balance
um I do have an emergency fund right now
of about twenty five thousand dollars
um I have a portfolio of
um stock Investments that uh
predominantly cash right now in my
brokerage account at about twenty five
thousand dollars and I also have which
included my Severance um in my checking
account I have about 30 30. okay so the
day you get employed you can write
checks and be debt free yep yes there's
not a cash though which is kind of what
I'm calling in because I'm trying to
figure out how to best handle this as
far as the job goes I'm not too
concerned about finding another job I
think my past experiences will help me
get that I'm kind of grappling with the
thought that it might not be as much
since things are trying to like
normalize right now in the market oh
maybe it's more
um I think it's more yeah that would be
great I really do what are you doing
Tech
uh so I do um uh business and operation
strategy okay
all right yes I'm not I'm not a uh an
engineer or coder unfortunately but um I
I do help the business side of tech grow
um so
um there's that part
um however the kicker that I mentioned
before is that I
decided to Branch out and I bought a
small business last year
um you know it was growing doing very
well
um there's a SBA loan attached to that
which you can imagine comes with a
personal guarantee how much uh 20 the
remaining principal is 209 all right
hold on hold on a minute we'll come back
to you and we'll talk about this after
the break this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
personality is my co-host we're talking
to Paul in New York City he's got about
um
he's got about 80 000 bucks in the bank
and he's got about eighty thousand bucks
in debt until he opened a business now
he's got 209 in an SBA loan and he lost
his 150 000 Tech job is that a fair
summary of what you told me numbers wise
Paul
yep I mean I do have a 401k but I've
listened to your show long enough to
know not to touch that right so how much
is how much is in the 401K
uh 26. okay and how old are you
I'm 29. and what is this business that
you paid
two hundred and nine thousand dollars I
borrowed money for
yeah so it's actually a a salon a
Grooming Salon
um so it's it's for for pets okay and
what'd you pay for it
um the uh purchase price was 235 and I
had 12 Equity
um as a requirement for the loan yeah
and um what is the net profit on this
business
well when I bought it it was a year
which which I understand was it was
owner operated which you know I'm I kind
of semi absentee it was 120 but with
changing business dynamics that I was
not prepared for it's looking at about
um this year probably like 70 80. what
business Dynamics changed
yeah so I mean one of the advantages
that it had in the beginning was that it
was hourly employees when historically
it's been commission employees
um and you know once once things changed
hands and the new year started um
considering how it's a required trade
for people because I'm not I'm not a
groomer myself
um you know they kind of advocated for
commission pay to be at like market rate
and with my hands tied behind my back I
kind of had to like
give in so that can really contract in
my margins and yeah so you're not
confused about who owned it you thought
they did
yeah you know I've never had employees
dictate to me in 30 years I've never had
employees dictate to me what I pay them
yeah you know that's a good point
um and it's a fortunate thing is you
know I tried to look for Alternatives
and fortunately in the area that I'm at
um because it's a skilled trade I guess
you have to go to school for it if you
want someone actually good
um you know they're they're that's kind
of like what the market is and I thought
I had more time uh to navigate that but
it came in I think you have I think you
have a business model problem and a comp
problem and a leadership problem in your
small business you need to go solve that
uh you sound like you are a victim to
circumstances and if you're going to
survive in business you can't be a
victim
you've got to get out there and attack
this and go okay I've got to get people
back on the books the way the old owner
had them on the books because everything
you're talking about existed when you
bought this business and the old owner
was running it at 120 and you managed to
make it down to 70 pretty quick so you
got to go clean this up uh and you're
supposed to know business strategy
that's what you're supposed to be doing
at the other place so you've got to go
you got to get your labor straightened
out and it probably means you need to
fire them all systematically not all at
once but you need to get you need to get
a new source of Labor start believing in
the system that you bought originally
and go back and restaff it and you
probably lost these people because they
think that they now think they run the
business they unionized on your some
kind of bull crap here I don't know what
happened and then then you need to get
this thing sold because you are not
equipped to run it
it's running you it's killing you you've
lost half of your value
on this one issue because they LED you
you didn't lead them
and you accepted that the marketplace
told you something and when you're in
business you tell the marketplace things
that's how you do this so you you got to
impose your will man uh and and then
you're going to get your back back get
get back out there and get your job at
150 again and then write a check and pay
off all your debts but you need to sell
this thing for 235 if you're lucky after
you get your labor cost straightened out
and um that's what's going on we deal
with this stuff all the time in entree
leadership I do the entree leadership
podcast I take calls from guys like Paul
every day and this is why you don't
borrow money to buy
small businesses SBA Loans are probably
the dumbest thing on the planet second
only to student loans
and so and both government funded by the
way government's going to help small
business out they just help this guy
who's 29 years old doesn't know beans
about anything go two hundred thousand
dollars in debt to buy pet grooming
did you just hear that this is what you
did with your tax dollars okay and now
it's just a you know it wasn't it yeah
no no no no no so you may need to go to
school and learn to pet groom for a
little while and it's almost like he
could have created his own pet grooming
business and earned 209 000 a lot faster
than buying I promise you you know what
I'm saying I promise you yeah I'm not
paying for that yeah that's that's too
easy it's two ease of Entry yeah on
something and that's where we're going
so yeah Paul um you got some serious
moves to make here but part of it is you
got to readjust your mindset and how
you're approaching this so you can get
the value back in this business and then
you need to get it sold uh you thought
you were diversifying and investing and
you weren't
uh you went deeply in debt and as you
said signed it personally so we got to
get you out of that as fast as we can
get you out of it but the best way is
you get the value back in the thing and
then let somebody that wants to be in
the pet grooming business that knows
something about it come along and pay
you what you paid hopefully that owner
for Ben is in Atlanta hi Ben welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up
yes I just had a question about
um contributing to a 401k when you're
trying to pay off debt so I'm in a
position where I've got some debt that
I'm working on paying off and my
employer matches fifty percent of 401k
uh contribution so I'm curious if it's a
good idea to continue to contribute
there and just use whatever extra I have
to pay the debts or to stop contributing
completely and pay the debts off and
then go full force into 401k I mean I
think it's great that they're offering
you that sort of a match and the good
news is after you pay off your debt
it'll still be there for you so if it
were me the whole thing about paying off
the debt right is you you need this
intensity you need as much money as you
can get your hands on going towards this
debt how much debt you have to pay off
uh just about a hundred thousand a
hundred thousand so man you need every
dollar so instead of putting that money
to your 401k pull that money back out
have that available to you to put
towards this debt and my guess is man
you're going to be what's your income
about 125 000. all right in two years
you'll be ready to go
yeah you're going to live on nothing
beans and rice rice and beans so what we
figured out Ben is that what we're
suggesting you do is stopping your 401k
you're going to miss the match for two
years
that is mathematically incorrect advice
agreed
mm-hmm yeah it's weird as a matter of
fact in the financial world it's
Blasphemous right okay yeah and so
people call us uh Heretics all the time
we should be burned at the stake but
what we've discovered is the number one
key to becoming wealthy is to be debt
free because you get control of your
most powerful wealth building tool which
is your income now once we know that
that's the number one key then what's
the number one or number two key to
becoming debt free what we've discovered
there is it is not a math problem as
much as it is an emotional decision and
this incredible Focus
and what you give up in math on the
match you gain in speed on getting out
of debt because you are laser focused on
one thing light dispersed simply lights
a room focused it's called a laser and
you can do surgery with it and so that's
what we're doing we're completely laser
focusing for a short period of time and
even though it on the surface it appears
to be mathematically incorrect on the
whole over a 10 or a 20-year picture it
is more mathematically correct because
you will actually get your hundred
thousand dollar Mountain climbed and be
done with it and there's something else
to add to that when you when you make
the choice hey I'm going to stop my
contribution that also signals okay this
this is serious this is important I
can't Lolly yeah
yes game all because you know you don't
want to miss out on that over this you
know five six years you gotta pay a this
debt and make that contribution pause
worth it yeah half butt doing five
things gets you nowhere
all in on one thing I'll bust it
and that's what happens everybody tries
to half butt do about six things at once
I'm gonna put money in my kids college
I'm gonna put money in my retirement I'm
gonna put money extra on the house I'm
gonna go on a vacation I'm gonna use
credit card points I'm going to half
foot my life away and end up with no
freaking money and that's what most
Americans do
[Music]
come on
[Applause]
thank you for joining us America Jade
wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Daniel's in Pensacola hi
Daniel how are you
hey Dave Jade how are you guys doing
great how can we help
all right so I just got a quick question
um it's a planning question I'm in the
military and heading be changing uh
locations in 2025
uh we did buy we purchased our home here
in Pace Florida and we absolutely love
our area it's unfortunate that I have
one more place to go before I retire
from the military
and I know uh we've gone through all
where we anticipate being on baby step
four in 2025 just to get you
um just a head uh kind of an idea where
we're heading towards and I want to know
what to do because we don't want to lose
our home here we want to come back here
we love our church here we love our
community here and I know the Navy's got
three more years out of me once I leave
from here in 2028 I'm done and we've
thought about some things in my wife and
we just want to know what the right
thing to do is I really don't want to
sell my home but I want to do what's
financially smart so the options I've
brought to the table with me what I've
talked about is hey how about I'll leave
wherever the Navy sends me you stay here
with the kids and after three years I'll
come back and I'll roommate with someone
what not
but I don't think that's smart
relationally uh and we thought about
maybe increasing our savings just a
little bit more so that we could
anticipate the risks of renting it out I
don't know I don't know what the right
thing to do is here and we don't want to
lose this community
and our low interest rate right now
um
again I know selling it might be the
best option just based on what I've
listened to in the past yeah I just
don't want to lose we love this Daniel
how long you been serving
15 years now um
yeah thank you for your service thank
you for your service
paid a price and you moved all over the
world
um yes yeah if you move take your wife
with you
Life's Too Short dude okay and then you
decide what you're going to do with the
house wean typically and we work a lot
as you know Daniel we work with the
military a lot
thousands and thousands of military
folks have gone through Financial Peace
University in the championship program
in other places okay so while we we do a
lot of interface with the military we
love you guys and uh what happens a lot
as you've probably heard me say in the
past is every time you get stationed you
buy a house you end up with rental
properties dotted all over the map of
your history
and that's a really bad method for
collecting rental properties your your
goal is a little different okay your
goal is I'm going to come back to this
house I love our because I love this
community I love this church
um you know if I could hold my nose and
be away from my wife I just let her stay
here but that's a little rough I don't
think I could do that so you you can do
whatever you want to do but I couldn't
do that so I would move them with me
which means that either the house is
sitting empty or you're renting it both
of both are hard on a house
because I don't care
the best renters in the world when you
move back in your home after someone
else lived in your home it is emotional
it's yuck it's not the same home it's
yuck the spirit has changed you know
what I'm saying and I mean I I own a
house that I used to live in and I don't
I cannot imagine this and I've walked
back through it several times when you
know when we've renovated it for renters
you know it's 20 years since I've lived
in that house and it's get every time I
go through it it gets weirder
when I walk in there it's just it's like
going back to your old elementary school
crap shrinks you know
you know it's just like the room shrunk
it's like how did we even golly you know
it's not like we're spoiled brats or
snobs or something but it's just the
world is weird the appliances are going
to be three years more outdated the roof
is going to be three years older the
weeds are going to be three years taller
and start to look like trees and you
know it's just a thing so I I can I can
if you want to do it and keep that house
the thing you've got to be prepared for
is you're going to spend some money when
you come back more than you think
putting that house back into Daniel
condition
okay and
um and smell and everything else and uh
and and it's still going to be an older
house when you move back into it I
personally have owned enough real estate
and I grew up in the real estate
business Mom and Daddy our furniture
when I was a kid our furniture was
trained to jump on the truck I mean we
moved all the time right so um I I don't
have a lot of emotional tie to houses
it's just a stupid house there's one on
every corner so if it was me I'd sell in
about 30 seconds I don't want to deal
with long distance Runners and I'm
certainly not gonna move back in after I
rented that house it's too weird for me
uh so I just moved back to the community
buy another house down the street or buy
a house in a newer neighborhood that's
near that church and start my life again
in Pensacola after I retire from the
Navy that's what I would do I wouldn't
keep it I think you're putting too much
stock in this house being your method to
return to Pensacola yeah I think that
sometimes where when there's something
that you want right and you want to have
this thing and you know the method of
you keeping it is not the smartest
choice right you know that it's not the
smartest choice but you'll do that in
order to say well this is the way I get
back but honestly in three years if it's
meant for you to be back in Pensacola
I'm pretty sure you'll be able to find a
house yeah they got houses they got more
houses and I got newer ones yeah and so
we've got a better one relinquish some
of that control and know if you're
supposed to go back to Pensacola there's
a housing market there if that's God's
plan for your life you'll be back you
know you'll be back at the church you'll
be back in the community and you'll be
able to find the right house for you and
I don't know what the real estate market
will be like I mean let's pretend that
the real estate market really sucked in
three years
and you could get a great buy right
and you might move up
substantially I mean what what if three
years from now was like 2008 the best
buying opportunity in real estate
history
I bought so much real estate in 2008
it's unbelievable how much real estate I
bought it was awesome it was the best
buying time ever I know it was hard
times for a folk and it's sad but I mean
it was the best time to buy real estate
because it wasn't that good for me Dave
let's just be honest if you're buying it
was like a dream freaking come true
we're buying stuff we're buying stuff a
quarter on the dollar it was incredible
oh man I don't know I'm not predicting
that by the way I think the real estate
Market's gonna get better personally but
I'm always half full class so um but
yeah I'm selling it Daniel and that's
all my reasons but in your case if you
choose to keep it I'm not going to yell
at you if you were going to be doing
three more stations before you got out
of the Navy I would just say you're
stupid don't sell it period don't do it
that's dumb okay but uh because you're
gonna end up long distance landlording
in five different places like I'll just
described I don't want to I don't want
you doing that but you're probably
coming back to Pensacola but I think you
are underestimating how difficult it's
going to be to move back into that house
it's going to need work we have this
idea and I'll tell you the other time
this comes up Jade and it's it's it's
also just as
um naive it's a nice way of saying it uh
delusional is what I was thinking but
it's a there's a dilute and an illusion
it's not delusion that we have is I'm
going to buy
the house I want to retire in 10 years
from now
you know I live in Kansas City and I'm
going to buy a house in Florida that I
want to retire into and I'm going to
rent it between now oh gosh and you know
by the way you have a 10 year old
dishwasher look or if you buy a
five-year-old house you got a 15 year oh
wait a minute no you have a new
dishwasher because you've replaced it
for the renter oh the hot water heater
hello I mean so you this is the stuff we
don't think about these appliances don't
have 30-year lives no and the people you
put in there aren't taking care of it
before we move to Tennessee we had
renovated our previous home top to
bottom it was just the way we wanted it
and I remember thinking oh man I wish
there was a way I could keep this house
because you know that it's like the guy
I love this community you know I'd love
to go back there even if we just
vacationed there but it didn't work out
financially right do you know we've gone
back to look at that house since
somebody bought it and has rented it and
it is so clear that's not our house
anymore it's not our house that's
exactly what I'm talking about the how
the house that I own is not my house my
home yeah anymore it's my house I own it
but it's not my home anymore it takes on
a different and and it's a great
neighborhood It's a Wonderful property
as an investment but
um I can't even get my kids to talk
about moving into it
and they grew up in it isn't that weird
how would you like to move back to your
childhood never okay it's the same
dadgum thing the same thing I'm talking
about that's exactly how it works very
fun it's a good discussion Daniel good
discussion thank you for calling in with
a question and again thank you for your
service to the country absolutely
amazing this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love
and create actual amazing relationships
thanks for hanging out with us Jade
washaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we talk about your life and
your money open phones are triple eight
eight two five five two two five and is
in Albany New York hi Anne welcome to
the Ramsay show
I'm a little nervous yeah no problem
okay so just for a little context my mom
passed away six years ago and I kind of
took it upon myself to make sure that my
youngest siblings are taken care of
um when it came to like meals grocery
shoppings or even just picking them out
for fun and just things like that
um how old how old are you
right now I'm 28. okay so you were 22.
you were 22 when you started this
program and how old are your youngest
siblings
to do the math real quick well so now
they would be 17 and uh and 21. okay so
they're almost they're almost grown
they're almost grown and you kind of
became a surrogate mom to them
um in a way
um I I did yeah
um and I usually started really trying
to get out of debt so I'm in baby step
number two and I paid off my car and I
was I found myself thinking I should
sell this to pay the rest of my debt
before or like I should sell things
around my house and stuff like that
um but then I realized I should probably
stop doing these things for my youngest
sibling right my little sister right now
what are you doing I called you mommy
what are you doing with her that cost
you money
um it's just mostly taking her out to
your grocery shopping for her a lot and
she's 17. why is she grocery shopping
was your dad not helping
he he's he's there
um he just works a lot or he he's
married and she lives in Mexico so he's
out of the country a lot as well he
doesn't leave money for food
um some
sometimes there's not a lot so I guess
I've I've been trying to figure out how
to like talk to him about it and I
always find myself not being able to
just because I just feel bad I guess or
I don't want my little sister to think
that I think she's a burden for me no I
don't want to help her that's not that's
not you look it's you need to explain to
your sister she's not the issue here but
you going to your dad and saying Hey Dad
part of the responsibility you got to
make sure there's money for food she
you're leaving her for however many
weeks on these trips she doesn't have
enough to eat
you need to Pony up some cash so there's
groceries that I'll make sure there's
groceries in the house but you're gonna
pay for them yeah you're the dad
yeah yeah now you can be a little nicer
than that I don't know because that's a
solid message right there
okay you know he's not a bad guy he's
just disorganized and he's got his eye
on this woman in Mexico and he's not
paying attention
okay am I right am I right
yeah okay then you just need to call him
out hey Dad you got a 17 year old up
here A minor you're supposed to be
caring for her needs I'm more than happy
to make sure there's groceries in the
house you're going to pay for them it's
going to be 500 bucks a month you need
to leave me 500 a month on my doorstep
and I'll take care of the groceries will
he do it if if you ask if you ask him
I don't know I'm hoping he will and see
there that right there he might do it
wait a minute why don't you know what in
his life has indicated he's not going to
take care of his daughter
um I feel like I've kind of had
conversations like this in the past not
this firmly but I've been like hey like
um your daughter needs this or that and
he'll be like okay I'll do it and then
he'll do it for like a week or two and
then then I'm calling him up and going
remember that part where you said you
were going to do it where's the freaking
five hundred dollars
you're supposed to take care of your
daughter
okay it's like his job hello
why why are you edging about that that's
a basic thing
because he no yeah it's not a cultural
issue this is Dad taking care of 17 year
old daughter it's his job to leave money
for food I get that he's in a different
stage of his life and this is the last
one getting ready to fly the nest great
got no problem with that and I got no
problem with you stepping up and helping
and that's nice of you to go do the
grocery shopping but for this to be a
net cost to you is absurd well he's made
it seem because you're too timid to get
in his face a little bit yo dad 500
bucks that's how one of my daughters
would do it yeah but he's made it seem
like them asking for that basic stuff is
a burden like I can hear that in your
language
am I right
yeah it's not a bird it's not a burden
I'm okay reminding him of his moral
obligation here
I'm perfectly okay if you want me to
give me his number I'll call him I mean
he needs to take care of his dadgum kid
I mean this is pretty patient yeah and
that's not a cultural thing and that's
not a his wife died six years ago thing
this is a you have a 17 year old sir
take care of her feed her put clothes on
her buy her shoes this is how life Works
Baba I mean it's not hard to miss you
know I mean and so yeah you don't need
to be timid about this man and I don't
know you know how you talk to him is how
we talk to people here on there you
start nice and at the point it becomes
ineffective you turn up the directness
and the volume that's right
and so we generally start nice with you
folk when you call in here but if you're
not hearing it we'll we'll work on
getting through to you it's our job
because we love you and we're we're
truth tellers and we're going to get
through to you that just that just
sticks in my craw Dave like she me as
another one of the siblings should not
have to continually be on dad to do dad
things that makes me mad it does but I
I'll give him I won't give him a pass on
the thing but I can see how he could get
there I mean he's kind of coasting off
into the next chapter this is the last
one to leave and Anne's been picking up
a lot of the emotional care she has and
uh and so he's kind of moved on you know
and it's like he forgot and all he needs
is somebody to remind him I doubt that
he's really that bad a guy he's just
he's a bit absent-minded in this
transitional period in his life is all
I'm saying and now again if you call him
out and he's not consistently leaving
money on the doorstep then I'm gonna
call it I'm on a little louder a little
louder I'm getting inconsistent vibes
from yeah that's what she well yeah and
I don't know there's probably a lot
going on here a lot I think so there's
more probably more than meets the eye
who knows he might be trying to get her
to leave the nest yeah well and it you
know she's going too soon yeah so um
that's how life works so
wow ouch ouch
but here's the thing
what's interesting is that the
the biggest problem that most people
have with their money and the biggest
asset that other people have with their
money is your relationships yes your
family your immediate family husband
wife
your little children your grown children
uh your idiot Aunt I mean whatever it is
these things intersect your pathway and
mess with the math of wealth building
and the more you the more what the
better you navigate this the better
chance you got a winning so you're
navigating relationships is part of
wealth building this is the Ramsay show
foreign
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money Jared is
with us in Coeur d'Alene Idaho hi Jared
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi guys hey I have a question regarding
cost of living
raises compared to inflation
I personally enjoy giving my customers
the cheapest service available yet to
keep up with inflation we have to give
raises how do those two things mesh
together and is there anything we can do
to battle the inflation as a business
owner
no not uh you know your job is not the
macro economy your job is to run your
business and that means take care of
your family and the families that you
pay
um that's your job the macro economy
discussion is that
um when things go up when the cost
of a loaf of bread the cost of a service
the cost of a uh a pack of hot dogs
whatever it is you want to call it a
gallon of gas when when the cost of that
goes up
one of the reasons the cost of the item
has gone up to the consumer when you
raise your prices in business is because
their cost of goods has gone up if their
cost of goods you know for instance if I
make a uh if we print a book
a a Total Money Makeover a baby steps
Millionaire's book well the cost of
paper has gone up 30 percent in the last
24 months
all right and so that's going to be
built into my pricing on the next book
that we put out agreed
if the uh if the cost of that book
includes a a dock worker to do the
shipping and a truck driver to deliver
it and both of those people get paid
more
by me to bring me that book then now the
cost of that book has gone up again the
paper cost went up and the labor cost
associated with delivering that went up
and so anytime you pay people more
inside your business you have to absorb
that in price changes and so price
increases are always not always but they
they either they have you have to do a
price increase to stay open otherwise
you're not profitable to cover your
actual cost of goods and cost of Labor
and when the cost of Labor goes up due
to cost of living raises or any other
races uh just a shortage of uh workers
an example of that is um you know we
told
when America got fouchied we told all of
the service industry all the waiters and
the people that make your beds at the
hotel and uh the people in the service
world that they weren't essential
and we sent them home
told them they couldn't work
if you're a restaurant worker you're not
allowed to work and in some places we
did that for a month other places we did
it for a year
when you tell people they're not
essential and then you want them to come
back
they remember how you pissed on them
last time
and so guess what you want to hire
somebody in the service world today
pre-covered you might have done that for
ten dollars now you might be looking at
twenty five dollars
because there's a shortage of workers in
this industry still to this day yeah
post covet
and so uh you know the economic
implications of covid are still shaking
out you create a labor disruption and a
labor price change
and we've seen it in other areas of
Labor as well our cost of what we pay
someone to work here at Ramsey has
changed in some of the areas pretty
dramatically and some of the we do comp
studies to see where they're charging so
yeah then that means that if I'm gonna
uh
be profitable I have to raise a price
somewhere and so that person that buys
that pays more and that's called
inflation
yeah you don't and you don't have to
feel guilty about it it's just part of
no part of it but I mean what what he's
pointing out and I think it's good for
people to hear out there is when you're
walking around with a little picket in
your hand and saying I demand
fifteen dollars I demand 22 dollars
where I was making 10 to work at
McDonald's
then the cost of McDonald's goes up to
cover your idea of you being worth more
then you don't get to about paying
more for stuff because you caused it
that's what I'm talking that's what he's
talking about and so you can't go I
don't like the fact that fast food
prices all went up and yet you're
walking around demanding that the cost
of labor at a fast food place go almost
freaking double
yeah and then and then can't fit you
know of course you know
um it's it's all connected you know I
mean that's why a child that's what
works because these businesses are not
evil and greedy but they also are not
not for profit that's right and they
have to make a profit to stay open and
oh by the way even non-profits are
profitable
a non-profit that isn't profitable
closes out of business it's out of
business it's gone non-profit is not a
not an actual dollar amount of they
didn't make more than they spent it's
just an accounting entry and an IRS
designation
but they actually you know your church
has to take in more
than it puts out otherwise it closes
so non-profits are profitable hello and
you know and so if the cost of
electricity at your church that goes up
then there you go I mean you're gonna
you're gonna if the cost of Staffing at
your church goes up because you're
competing in the marketplace for that
creative position at the church that
music director at the church you're
competing with the marketplace then that
you know it costs more to operate that
organization and some organizations
haven't survived that that's right so
yeah inflation includes cost of Labor
and when you had a labor destruct
disruption like the quarantines created
uh we haven't seen we've seen most of
the end of it but we haven't seen the
complete end of it yet
um it will calm down and smooth out
eventually but even a little three
percent five percent cost living raise
then gets built into the thing and you
can't really in business I can't
stand against that and go well I just
refused to raise my prices well you can
refuse to stay in business you know
that's just kind of dumb so so the next
book you buy from us get ready the price
is going to be more because hello you
know those 10 sales we run there have to
be 12.50 they're about done I'm just
saying we're about done with a ten
dollar sale because ten dollar sales
about backward it's about upside down
now and I'm about done with it so that
was helpful for a while but been doing
them been doing them for 10 years and
you know cost of paper kicked kicked my
butt and so I'm gonna pass on the butt
kicking all right that's how this works
that's how that's how it works y'all I
mean it's just this is how it is so if
you think it's otherwise then you're
being naive so but it's interesting to
me that we teach so little Civics and so
little economics today that people can't
make a basic connection between what's
connected I demand to be paid more but
then on the other hand I'm gonna
about inflation yeah no I don't when you
freaking caused it
you're the essence of it I mean you know
I can't believe the cost of bread well
it costs about twice the labor to put
the bread on the Shelf now that's right
that it did so look I mean almost double
it's crazy and you can't even get the
help can't get people show up because
they're sitting at home in their
mother's basement playing Nintendo it's
nuts so
now we don't have that problem at Ramsey
because we're not dealing with that
level of labor we're dealing with a high
class you know generally here so we got
a whole different whole different set of
uh uh things that we deal with that are
wonderful by and large but yeah it's a
it's a great discussion Jared and you
know the problem was you pulled the
string on the monkey so you got you got
the Soap Box you got the soapbox
response because I can go on them for
days about this but it is interesting
how ignorant yeah you know some of this
wealthy quality stuff is and all this
stuff it's just they're ignorant of the
connection the unintended consequences
of their little shallow ideas yeah
absolutely and where they're going so
I'm glad that he pulled the string yeah
well you just every so often I have to
get out of my system
uh we will look back in time and say
fouchy wow just wow this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt-free stage Jordan and Kayla are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you better than I deserve welcome
where do y'all live Mount Vernon Ohio
fine welcome to Nashville thank you and
how much debt have you two paid off
together since we got married
okay so one of you started or both of
you started before marriage
good and how long did the 80 000 take
how long you been married about 8
months good for you and how long before
that were you working on it I started in
2020 toward the beginning of 2020. so
three years three years total yes for me
yeah good and uh your range of income uh
let's just say since you've been married
would you start at 18 months ago and
what are you now I believe
was around 8
and now it's around 1 10. actually good
good for you too what do you two do for
a living
Jordan oh I'm uh the maintenance of the
Columbus Zoo okay great what about you
um so I started this journey as a
reporter and I got out of that toxic
industry and I now
I now work for myself
um doing video marketing so I get to
share positive stories for businesses
now instead of all the negative crap
that you hear on the news very cool yeah
it is a hard business it's a steady diet
especially 2020 I was like I'm done and
then I started listening to you I was
like oh he has so many good valid points
yeah it's just hard just really hard
welcome thank you good to have you guys
I'm proud of you okay so before you get
married you're working on this stuff and
so Jordan y'all are dating and Kayla
goes hey we gotta have the talk yes did
that happen really kind of so okay all
right I'm just making this up I didn't
know so originally it was kind of like
the Jesus talk first
you know are you Christian do you
believe in God and I said yes and then
she said well what do you think about
this book
and I was like well I don't know yet so
she gave it to me and I read it I was
like got on the cover ain't much I was
like well it makes it don't make sense
yeah okay so I was like yeah I'm on
board it's like that yeah it was easy I
mean I read it and just what my
grandparents did kind of Common Sense
how's this guy making a living
absolutely yeah let's go all right yeah
I was outdoor dashing after I got off
the news and he was like what are you
why are you out delivering food and I
was like well there's this plan that I'm
on and then talked about the book and he
just he's like yeah this makes sense
there was no I didn't have to convince
him or anything thankfully
um I just came with like 100 Grand of
debt and yeah if you're not dumb you you
read the book and you're just like yeah
it makes sense so Jordan you didn't have
prior debt but only Kayla did I had a
little bit I had a car payment okay so
you got after yours before the marriage
yeah and and paid that off as well uh
when we started talking so we started
talking first you know and we started
dating and then she gave me the book and
she's like okay you know there's no
package deal yeah there wasn't that much
left on my car payment I just I had it I
had it saved already and I just wrote a
check said okay
and then I was free and clear yeah and
then we started but if it was just that
easy I know right I love that yeah we
got old tortash over here and Jordan
Strokes a check yeah yeah so there we go
for you yeah good for you must be good
to be you yeah all right very cool guys
very cool so you found him and he starts
acting like that and you go I think this
one's a keeper oh yeah I knew right away
when when he just was able to he was
teachable like he humbled himself and he
was like he got the book on his own I
didn't tell him to go get it and he was
like yeah this makes total sense and it
just we really haven't had any fights
about money we take our frustrations out
on each other
no actual fights we were in agreement
thankfully well what's been the hardest
part I mean obviously you read the book
it makes sense but that doesn't make it
easy right just because just because it
makes sense so what was the hard part
for you
none of it was easy
um we lived in a camper for two years
whoa yeah that was that wow okay I'm
looking at it on my screen it was it was
run down
um yeah so we lived in that for two
years that was hard wow constant working
making more than we'd ever made but not
you know immediately it goes out to our
right yeah now that you're completely
free how does it feel
uh words can't I can't put into words
how it feels um like our whole Future
Has Changed I've changed just every
single area of my life where bringing a
child into the world without debt that's
not how I grew up at all so come on love
that it's a complete change your family
tree yes yes 100 yeah like oh you gosh
your baby's not gonna even know what
debt is until you teach them and you can
teach them from a space of not having
debt as opposed to being smack dab in
the middle of it yes I went through uh
well my family went through bankruptcy
as well when I was a child just you know
losing our home divorce a lot of you
know not so great things you don't have
to have that I don't have to have that
life now it stops that's right I'm so
proud of you thank you guys very very
cool who was cheering you on as you were
doing this
you're living in a camper somebody had
to be hating on you me yeah I mean no I
mean outside friends are going what are
you people for the most part yes like my
friends you know family they're
accounting what are you doing my family
they kind of understood it I would say
for the most part
um I don't think they thought that we
were gonna be able to do it as long as
we did like I said a little over two
years living in a camper yeah that's
rough yeah uh friends it was just kind
of like
there's not a whole lot of questions
asked I guess they just kind of were
like all right oh you're going to do
what you're gonna do good friends mind
their own business absolutely and you
know we didn't have any conversations
like that with my friends they're just
kind of like wow you're just doing it
okay
it's Jordan there you go they did that
they didn't ask I didn't you know I
didn't tell them why I love you I love
it wow how's it feel to be completely
free it's a huge weight off your
shoulders yeah huge so I don't need to
ask if it's worth it it's worth it yes
way to go okay do it what do you tell
people the main key to getting out of
debt is
I had several I'm definitely in tithe
follow God's word and you will be
blessed through this process don't skip
out on the tithe make that first first
priority amen um humble yourself if you
don't know what you're doing admit it
and learn a different way
don't be a victim
um I don't care what you've been through
in life you can pull yourself up you can
make a change for yourself it's not the
government's responsibility to pay off
your debt it's not anyone else's
responsibility you sign the papers you
pay it off yourself
um and don't care what other people
think come on we probably have one of
the crappiest cars out there cracks in
the windshield you just gotta stop
carrying uh stop trying to impress
people with material things it's uh as
soon as you do that you're about to
really build some wealth yeah because
most people they care what other people
think never get there well done well
done YouTube it's so good thank you
proud of you hey we've got the live and
give box for you it's the baby steps
millionaires book which is where you're
on the way to for sure The Total Money
Makeover book which started this whole
discussion with YouTube and uh the
Financial Peace University membership if
you hadn't been through go ahead and go
through it if you have and you want to
give any of that away give it all away
use it yourself it's the live and give
box we're proud of you guys thank you
well done Heroes that little baby man
got some great parents very cool stuff
Jordan and Kayla Mount Vernon Ohio 107
000 paid off 80 in the last 18 months
since they've been married to make it
did that making 80 to 110. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
[Applause]
I love it so good I love it
there is nothing like a baby on the way
or the birth of a baby to give you
unbelievable motivation to get your crap
together yeah I mean and just the
emotion that she had is valid completely
valid going this baby as for me and my
come on that's for me and my house we're
not gonna be normal yeah it stops here
it stops here it doesn't matter where
you come from all that matters is where
you're going to Condoleezza Rice says
and she came from some interesting
circumstances on to be one of the more
impressive women in the world today so
candy knows her stuff
doesn't matter where you're coming from
all that matters is where you're going
to we've all come from some stuff
where are you going two that's the next
question this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us Melanie is in Seattle
hi Melanie welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you so much for taking my call
Dave and Jade I'm so excited to be
talking to you both you too what's up
so I am wondering if this is the right
thing to upgrade my hooptie that I love
so much actually I mean baby said 3B
while my husband and I were both in baby
step 3B currently saving up for a house
um and I'm just wondering if I should
take a little bit of that chunk to get a
upgraded car
I learned about you in 2019 I actually
had the flashy Mercedes and then I went
and I was like nope cannot do this
payment anymore and I paid it off as
fast as I can to get rid of that lease
and in the meantime I was able to cash
flow my first CRV
um and I actually paid cash for it and
so it's a little older I do love it I
enjoy it but I'm wondering if this is
the right time to okay a better one
what's it worth it's worth six thousand
dollars what are you what's your
household income
a hundred and sixteen thousand dollars
okay a year
um and how much would you spend to
upgrade it
I would spend about fifteen thousand
dollars so moved to a twenty one
thousand dollar car
uh twenty thousand yeah yeah twenty one
yeah and um
how much do you have saved for your
house
fifty thousand dollars okay
this slows down it slows you down by
fifteen thousand bucks right
and just to clarify that fifty thousand
that is totally home money there's no
there's none of your other savings
locked into that correct
that's correct that's just full money
Melanie you've done a really good job
you're out of debt you have an emergency
fund you have fifty thousand saved for a
down payment on a house you make over a
hundred thousand dollars a year
I think you are more than capable of
making this decision
I think it's a little bit emotional for
me because of
seeing what I went through without like
lease and I'm so happy that I found you
and so I just never never again will you
accidentally do a car deal you will
always be intentional for the rest of
your life
exactly one thousand percent that's good
I'm intentional with my car deals
and um you know I and I don't even have
to be now but I am I'm you know okay
this is the you're charging me what you
know no I don't think so yeah you know
so you know it's that that kind of a
thing and this will be the first this
will probably be your most expensive
cash purchase right
yeah
yeah so that that feels different I mean
when you're used to going in a place in
financing it's a different feeling it's
a good feeling but it is also like oh my
goodness I'm about to put twenty one
thousand dollars of cash on the you know
on the table here yeah it does it
definitely feels different but let me
tell you when you get in that car and I
mean you did it with your CRV just not
to the tune of 21 000 but when you drive
that thing home you're gonna feel so
good yeah I my point earlier is is that
you've done such a good job I want you
to have confidence in you because you
are valid your decision making
process your critical thinking skills on
this money stuff is really solid so
you're not going to everything you've
given me tells me you're not going to
make a bad decision so I'm okay if you
drive the hooptie a while and I'm okay
if you move up and I'm okay if you move
up a little bit but not as much as you
were thinking I'm okay with any of those
three ideas and because I'm okay with
Melanie and I think you're going to do
really well I think you're going to a
good decision
don't you I definitely do I I'm so proud
of her so many people Dave that's that's
the mental block that a lot of people
struggle with is wait a second buying a
car in cash I they'll they'll go with
you on the idea of paying off your
existing car they'll walk with us on
that but then this idea of I can
actually then save
to upgrade and buy something out writing
cash that is a whole different mind
shift that takes place yeah my oldest
child Denise when I was teaching her to
ride a bicycle
she just trusted me she said if that's
what I can do I can do it Rachel however
questions everything
and so sometimes when we tell people
they can pay cash for a car it's like
Rachel looked at me when I said I'm
going to let go of the seat you're going
to balance and she's like
say you right you say what you know
because she had never done it yeah and
then once she did it it wasn't a thing
but until she had done it there wasn't
anybody else talking it that's right
you're gonna trust it look full
disclosure when I first read Total Money
Makeover I'm like okay like Dave I'm on
board with this the two things that I
was like I don't know Dave was the car
in cash and then your your credit score
will drop to zero when you've paid off
all your debt and you'll be able to get
out I have a minor heart attack thinking
about it
which tells us that we think that we're
art we're worshiping at the altar of the
great fire yeah yeah who's your provider
but you just got to walk it through
there it is
in Spokane Washington hi Ed how are you
I'm great how are you guys doing better
than we deserve what's up
my call my family's a Han the YouTube
show it's our dinner show of choice wow
we're putting it out there Dave and Jade
for dinner what's for dinner Ed dinner
theater barbecue all right my question
for you actually about my mother-in-law
she's 85 years old and she's had some
medical setbacks this year and basically
the family and her have decided to
basically sell her property and move her
into a senior living area
the concern is she makes 2100 in Social
Security but the apartment is twenty six
hundred dollars and that's like the
minimum cost right so obviously if more
cares needs in the future what's the
property selling for
she's sitting at a little over three
hundred thousand okay and um so the
question is with the interest rates
where they are is a CD ladder a good
place to put the money so to help her
cash flow you know that's her an estate
that's 300 000 is her nest egg she has
very little there's a tiny IRA and a
tiny bit in savings like 10 000. I need
to probably do better than that
um
you know because I I you know she she
only needs six thousand dollars a year
off of this
and she's 82. so the chances are even if
she got zero interest the chances of her
burning all the way through it before
she dies is almost zero
right 500 bucks A month's a negative
right now right
correct yeah she likes to give to
Charities as well and that's kind of the
family right now she's the charity
um I've tried to tell her that first
charity is memo yeah
okay and once memo is taken care of Only
the Strong can help the weak
understood I didn't let my toddler carry
my newborn
so you gotta have the strengths to carry
people and right now she's got to make
sure she takes care of her that's her
first responsibility take care of your
own household first
so yeah I'm as long as we get all that
straight you can invest it however you
want I would sit down with a good with
her is her mind good and clear
for the most part yes okay I would sit
down with a good smart investor Pro and
talk to them about a fee uh uh you know
if you want to do some high interest
savings as part of it I would probably
end up investing some of it because
here's the thing if you could make
um
eight percent on it that's two thousand
dollars a month
and it lasts forever
that's not touching the principle
right okay that's what I'm looking at
and you know it but if you make if you
make nothing on it I mean divide six
thousand into three hundred thousand
that's a long time it's longer than she
lives
so you're not going to mess this up
unless you go put it in crypto or
something right I mean what you're not
gonna do you're not stupid okay so the
other concern is you know she didn't
have Medicare gap insurance and so with
these setbacks this year she's had to
pay a lot out of pocket so
um that's kind of our concern is that
any that's kind of mine I'm kind of
thinking an extra 2000 on top of our
2100 gives us forty one hundred uh and
you know we've got a little cushion here
to do some other stuff with have a
little bit of a life in addition to
paying the bills
okay and you know you're probably gonna
have to pick up some medical stuff here
or there you're probably gonna pick up
some personal care and comfort Creature
Comforts and stuff as we go along uh but
I mean statistically
I think we can all agree an 82 year old
that lives to 92 would be a long time
that's right and I think if you look at
the Actuarial tables that's what you'll
see I know we're talking about your
wife's mother or grandmother I don't
want to be mean but I mean so 10 into
300 is 30 a year yeah and so you're okay
you just need to be careful you know to
be super aggressive and you don't have
to be super lean
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Jade wash
all Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones a triple A
825-5225 Mia is in Massachusetts hi Mia
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you for having me sure what's
up
so about three weeks ago I went to one
of those required retirement meetings
for work and they referred me to a debt
counselor due to my debt and the debt
counselor recommended bankruptcy so I
went home and spoke with my husband we
bought your book The Total Money
Makeover read it in two days we're fully
committed
um we have about 1500 already in an
emergency fund so we're trying to move
on to baby step two with the debt
snowball we stopped using all our credit
cards we listed all our debts in order
and we're trying to make a budget the
budget is really hard because I have
five kids and it seems like emergencies
are constantly happening last month we
spent over three thousand dollars in car
repairs and just yesterday we had like a
surprise 50 saxophone fee for my son
there's just so many unexpected fees and
costs for seven people bumping around in
the world prior to This Money Makeover
we live really simply we only went out
to dinner like once a semester for good
report cards our only vacation this year
was a four day camping trip in the tent
so you know we're selling everything
we're selling so much what the kids
think they're next but I'm worried that
we're still going to end up with too
much months and not enough money and
that we won't even be able to get to the
debt snowball how much debt do you have
I have
um
let's see 2034
3747 with the car and not including my
mortgage and how much of that is the car
10. okay and what's the other 37
one last kid in braces
okay
all right so 37 30 33 000 in credit card
debt and um so you've been covering all
of this chaos and disorganization and
shortages with credit cards in the past
that's where 33 000 came from am I right
okay so you made a good decision because
bankruptcy really won't help you
you'll be right back here 10 months
later if you don't fix this on the core
what's your household income
150 000 between the two of us before
taxes
okay
you're all right what's your house
payment
920 a month oh you're definitely all
right okay you're gonna make it all
right here here's what first happens
okay these on it to start with saxophone
payments aren't a surprise
that's a known quantity that everyone
knew was coming
just no one is organized in this house
enough to bother to tell everybody
what's going on
okay but I mean that that's not they
don't suddenly say this is going to
happen uh so there's two opportunities
but but we've got to one of the things
we had to do our kids our three kids was
to train them to not bring us any
surprises they've got to tell us about
everything early and often so we can get
it into the budget or they're going to
not get to do it
that's what ends up happening and about
the time they miss out on one thing
because they they forgot to tell us that
little Georgie has a birthday party well
you don't go because we don't have it in
the budget to battle Georgie a gift and
you're not going over there looking like
a freeloader so you're a little butt
staying at home next time you'll tell us
about the time I did that twice all of a
sudden they became experts on planning
at eight years old
yeah and so what's happening is you guys
you know you have a chaotic life because
you have a big family everybody working
everybody's running different directions
and the chaos is showing up in the
disorganization of the handling of the
money and it's costing you all of your
peace and a lot of your money
because you can't you can't because your
budget Jayden I both did it in our head
while you were telling us you're you're
completely able to make these this work
yeah the good news is you know up until
this point you were just flying by the
seat of your pants but now you've read
the book and you're like okay we've got
to get on a budget and now you're going
to start to implement that and you will
find you know it's going to take a
couple of months to iron that out and
get it really where it's you know you're
not going over it or busting it in
certain areas that where you're really
understanding okay this is what we spend
this is what we can spend and in your
situation there's you got five kids
there's gonna be a lot of line items on
there and it's something that because of
the size of your family this idea of set
it and forget it is not it shouldn't
work for anybody but it's certainly not
going to work for you exactly you're
gonna have a new budget every month and
it's going to include this month a
saxophone payment next month does not
um hopefully uh and um uh you know this
month has a field trip next month does
not and you're also going to have some
miscellaneous category for just
miscellaneous kid things that come up
you're all because it's predictable that
one of them is going to the pediatrician
at least every 60 days
with five of them okay that's fairly
predictable whether it's uh the flu or
stitches I don't know but one of them is
going to go get a Doc Bill
am I wrong
no you're right how old are they
um they are 11 13 16 my 18 year old just
graduated high school my 21 year old has
autism so he's going to be with us a lot
longer so so it's not as much as not as
much pediatrician as it is they eat a
lot football game basketball game all
that stuff yeah there you got a house
full of teenagers so they eat everything
in sight and they and their you know the
hormones are pumping so there's a lot of
drama and there's a lot of stuff going
on I mean and if you let all of that
infect your budget instead of you guys
controlling see the trick with budgeting
is you'd flip it and and it's hard it's
very difficult for the first three
months but you flip it and you say I'm
going to make the money behave I'm not a
victim to a lack of money I'm going to
tell this money what to do and by doing
that I'm going to make some choices I
don't think you've been overspending I
don't think you're out of control I
don't think you're buying a bunch of
crap you can't afford you didn't call me
up with a 57 000 car payment you call me
up with a ten thousand dollar car
payment and you make a hundred and fifty
but I do think you've got autism and
teenagers and you got a bunch of them
and so you're just in the middle of
chaos and disorganization and that's
eating your lunch literally it's eating
your money yeah and so you have got to
get up above it and make all this crap
calm down line up and behave yeah and
that includes some of the behaviors with
the kids but most of all it includes uh
you guys saying okay this is where every
dollar is going because if you start at
the top with your household income and
you stop your 401k and you're not
getting a tax refund because you're not
having too much withheld and you don't
have anything coming out of your check
except taxes and you sit there and you
go okay I got 150 000 bucks I got a 900
house payment I got a car payment I got
food that is equal to this and there's
no restaurants in that because I'm
getting out of debt and I've got uh and
you lay this out you can do this you can
do this Mia there's room in this it's
possible it doesn't you don't feel
powerful right now but you've taken the
first big steps away from the Cliff of
falling off into bankruptcy and you're
just three steps back inside we'll help
you okay but uh first thing I want to do
is encourage you and tell you there is
enough money here to make this work and
it's going to be hard but you can do it
you've got the stuff but it is a matter
of taming the chaos tiger Hang on we're
going to put you into Financial Peace
University and if you need more help you
call us back we'll help you more okay
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save 45 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host our question
of the day is brought to you by
neighborly your hub for Home Services
neighborly has 19 service Brands
Nationwide and a network of local
service pros window Genie ground skies
and Mr Handyman just to name a few what
a great company visit neighborly.com to
find the available service providers
near you all right today's question
comes from Samuel in Texas a friend of
mine got me hooked on baby steps and
gave me a copy of your book The Total
Money Makeover I read it I loved it and
I'm making my way through the baby steps
I've paid off all my credit card debt
two cars and have a thousand dollars in
my emergency fund way to go but I cannot
get my wife on the same Financial page
that I'm on she thinks we have her money
and my money she won't budget she won't
have a joint bank account with me I feel
like we are never going to achieve our
financial goals or become completely
debt free if we are not on the same page
what do I do man this right here this is
the this is the quandary that so many
people find themselves in
it sounds like based on the question
that he did this while they were still
married it wasn't like he did this ahead
of time I'm guessing
um
I don't see anything that indicates that
he did it before they got married so it
sounds like he kind of just took matters
into his own hands and said look this is
the way this is the way to Freedom I'm
gonna start whether you want to come
with me or not and even in the midst of
that she still doesn't want to get on
board you know Dave in those situations
there is something going on that's
deeper than money there's a marriage
issue there's clearly a trust issue if
somebody a spouse doesn't want to share
money or a bank account with another
spouse it's like you don't trust me I
don't care you do not trust me and that
is an issue and so obviously I would
suggest you got to go to counseling got
to
and then there's a situations where the
others Dave we were talking about this
this morning there's a situation where
the other spouse won't go to counseling
and it's like what the heck do you do
she needs a vocab rehab obviously but
you cannot force people to do things all
you can do is tell them hey
you know this is bothering me I think
that we should be on the same page I
think that we should go to counseling
that's really all you can do and then
lead by example yeah
all the data this is me if I'm you
talking to her
I've gotten out of debt
I've proven that this process works I'm
winning with money and all the data says
that if we want to build wealth the
probability of us doing that without
working together is very low
all the millionaire statistics tell us
that and you can read baby steps
millionaires if you want to know that
they're in there okay as we did the
largest study of millionaires ever done
in North America
we discovered that almost none of them
do it without spousal agreement
so it needs to be solved and so
um you know I I and I think Jade's right
I think something else is going on here
so why is it
that she doesn't want to combine your
money
why
she thinks you're going to control her
you've been so enthusiastic with this
Ramsay stuff you turned my name into a
cuss word in your house
uh you're you're you know you think
you're being excited and fired up and
she feels like she's getting ready to
lose her Vote or she grew up in a house
where she was controlled by money one of
them something's something is driving
her fear yeah
but really the the quality of your old
relationship
is being impacted by whatever that is
and money's just a part of it there's
other things that she doesn't want to
share with you too
for some reason you know she don't feel
safe with this and I'm not saying you're
a bad guy I am saying you might be
overly fired up and enthusiastic and you
went running off with your hair on fire
that's right and all she sees is smoke
and so um she's like I don't wanna
you're gonna come in here you're gonna
come over here and bring that crap over
here and so uh but you need to get into
why it is she don't trust you does she
think you're you know you've fallen for
some cult or scam or something or why is
it what's going on yeah if he's a guy
that's like all bringing home and I'm
saying he is but if he's a guy who's
always bringing home some hair brain
scheme and this is another one in a
series of that's I mean my wife we've
been married 41 years and occasionally
she'll go you know I don't know if you
are but you sound like you're scheming
and scamming
and it activates that and hurt yeah you
know like back in the day when we went
broke she sees a little glimmer of that
portion of Dave and she don't want to
deal with that guy again yeah you know
and that's my wife that's my wife
talking about it so yeah but it it is
not okay
for this to continue the way it is yeah
it's not good for you it's not good for
her it's not good for the probability of
your wealth building it's not good for
your relationship because there's
something under here that's boiling and
it will come to the surface it will come
blasting to the surface in the most
inopportune way and in the most horrible
of circumstances or you guys are going
to draw it to the surface and heal it
yeah so I'm drawing into the surface I'm
going to start with some conversations
of why don't you trust me
why don't you trust me enough you trust
me enough share my bed but you don't
trust me enough to share your checking
account that's kind of weird
that's kind of weird and I gotta say if
you're married let's just say it's not
his abrasive personality if you're
married the hope is that you know enough
about your spouse that even if you don't
know exactly what it is you might be
able to go I think I I think I get where
this is coming from right and try to
approach them on that level is it from
her former marriage yeah you know or her
dad run off with the money when she was
16. right left her mom high and dry I
don't know why it is she you know maybe
it isn't him maybe it's something like
there that she's but she said I'm never
going to let them get to me right
whoever they are and now you're they
yeah well that's got to be fixed yeah
that's got to be fixed so yeah if she
won't go to if she can't begin to have a
discussion about this calmly and
rationally and say what's really going
on here honey why don't you trust me
then you need to go see a marriage
counselor and hopefully she'll come with
you but if she won't your marriage
counselor will give you more ways to
talk to her because I can promise you 10
years from now you guys won't be
together if you don't solve this and
that's good Dave even if she won't go he
still needs to go anyway because you'll
get words on how to speak you'll be you
know what marriage counseling is is
relationship training
that's what it is you're going to
training class on how to do relationship
and the counselor can you know guide you
through how to work on this and then
guide you through how to deal with your
own emotions on it because I you're
going to reach a point that um you're
disgusted with her lack of trust that's
right who wants to hang out with
somebody disrespecting you all the time
yeah and you have to have mutual goals
in a marriage you have to have something
that you're working towards together
otherwise it's like okay you will end up
going in different directions quite
literally yeah yeah you're growing
together you're growing apart there's no
in between Sebastian is with us in Los
Angeles hi Sebastian welcome to the
Ramsay show
Hi how are you doing thanks for taking
my call sure what's up
so um I have about 150 000 in student
loans
um I just graduated so this would be my
first time you know tackling this debt
holy crap what's your degree in daughter
your doctor or lawyer
so a little bit of I'm a doctor a PhD
and um PhD in what
uh uh oncology research and I I'm a
nurse practitioner as well okay good so
you got a new gig doing this
I have a new gig making what
250 000. thank you Jesus that's good
thank you Jesus big shovel good but you
in Los Angeles though yeah but that's
okay yeah and you're single you're
single right I'm not
um I'm not single oh you're married okay
uh engaged oh okay when are you getting
married
oh that's what I I kind of wanted to
discuss because
um I have been kind of pushing marriage
back no no no no no no no no no no you
only got 150 000 in debt you make a
quarter million dollars a year what'd
you make two years ago
what was your household what was your
personal income two years ago while
you're in school huh uh about 90 000.
okay so live on 80. live on 80.
and pay your loans off in two years
but don't wait to get married on student
loan debt just go pay it off yeah that's
not really a reason that's not a reason
to not get married yeah it's 250 minus
90 leaves 160. not counting taxes that
gets you out of debt in two years
easy live on less than you used to live
on
and um don't be buying a bunch of crap
and have an inexpensive wedding let's
get married now Hee Haw and let's get
these loans paid off in the next two
years that's what I would do you can do
this you got a great income man
[Music]
[Applause]
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America we're so glad you're here open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
we're here to love you enough to tell
you the truth about your life and your
money it's what we do thanks for being
with us Justin is with us in Corpus
Christi hi Justin welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Dave I'm good to talk to you and are
you still doing better than you deserve
always better than I deserve brother
what's up
[Music]
a short back story with after I left my
mom and just after Christmas of 21
um her life insurance that redeemed was
400 000 and after I paid the funeral and
her expenses it was enough to get me out
of dead
so I finished baby step three back in
about six weeks ago actually and
honestly Dave um well at this point I'm
probably Blow Me I'm Scared I have lived
my entire life broke I was broke the day
I was born because I'm I'm the only
child of a single parent my mom we lived
in poverty my entire childhood so this
is
unknown worse than me if you know what
I'm saying and I don't I don't have the
income to buy a house right now so I'm
just curious I've always seen YouTube
videos that oh babysat 3B is supposed to
say 20 for a house but
um 42 single unattached no kids no media
family I don't need to buy a house right
now what um
you got 400 Grand
and I'm sorry
uh 100
000 100. okay and you pay the funeral
and you paid off how much debt
uh 48k in student loans I paid my car
off which was another 9 000 another 20
grand in Old medical and credit cards
it's only about eight months to find
them all in pay them all
okay how much money are you getting how
much money do you have left
um in my savings I have ten thousand
that's my that's my full funded
emergency fund okay and everything and
you're 100 Dead free and that's all you
ended up with Okay good all right I got
the picture I'd like to call it as that
was the last good mom made filming
because I told her about you and and
during 2020 I was trying to get on the
path and she said yeah that sounds great
go for it and if anything this was the
last gift to me it was hey get out of
debt I'm sorry sorry that's the way you
got it I'm glad it worked out good for
you
um what do you do what's your income
it's a restaurant it's
a messenger I make about 33.
okay
um so what are your career aspirations
what are you gonna do with your life man
you're 48. did you say you're 48.
I'm 42 42. okay
so what are you going to be doing when
you're 52 that's so much more exciting
and cool than what you're doing now
truthfully I haven't thought about that
I've been so focused on trying to be the
best leader I can because I work with a
lot of teenagers I need to set a good
example for them no I wasn't suggesting
you abandon your job I just asked you
what you were going to become
I hope you become a GM okay I like the
place I like the place I work at I work
I like the people I work with and okay
what is it what does a GM make
I believe
this is my old one just resign we're
getting a new one next week
um 48 .
okay I think so I I obviously never told
me my salary but they get a base salary
they they're only they're the only ones
on salary and then they get a bonus
based on the monthly business oh how
much the business does each month okay
all right good all right so we got a
plan that's good and why is it you don't
want to own a house
I just feel like it's a little
Superfluous specific I'm sorry
superfloors because I don't have a why
for kids I mean it's just me I live in a
one bedroom that's within my budget I
pay
669 employment plus utilities I'm
comfortable but at the same time I've
seen some of your old YouTube videos
where I mean I don't want to be stagnant
I mean I want to keep moving but yep
honestly I don't know the direction to
move well there is part of this that
you're looking at the Here and Now 42
years old right now you're unattached
maybe in five or ten years you won't be
you know you could there's this piece of
this puzzle that's an unknown and you
kind of have to think through that you
have to look at your feature the same
way Dave asks you hey what do you want
to be doing in five years what do you
want to be doing in 10 years you have to
ask yourself about your life in general
what do you want it to look like we've
seen how this money that your mom left
whether it's through Insurance how it's
changed your life right so you have the
ability to do that same thing in some
way right there's a purpose there is
still a purpose for you regardless if
you have a wife and kids and that
purpose can have Financial attachments
to it but more than that we know that
homeownership is a part of Building
Wealth and even if you don't want to buy
a home right now I do think it's
something that you should and can aspire
to
um with your income living in Corpus
Christi I think it's still something
that you can have I just think it's
something you're not used to like you
said you're not used to
where you're at financially and so you
don't know what it looks like to really
prosper in and of your own right on your
own and so it's like I've never seen
that before I don't well let's just stay
where we are I'm comfortable here
mentally and in every other way but I
would challenge you to move past that
and really dream beyond that because
that's what you're headed for yeah
that's good
and Justin on the on the logical side of
the economic side let's work through
that for a second
the short-term renting is not a problem
long-term renting is a problem and
here's why it's a problem
the property that you're living in is
going to go up in value in the next 10
years substantially
and the landlord is going to benefit
from that not you
so if you live in a property in Corpus
Christi let's say you bought a
two-bedroom condo okay is similar to
what you're in now and you paid 150 000
for it okay let's just make that up I
just made that up all right then in 10
years that thing's worth 250. you
and and you don't you lose that hundred
grand an increase in value because you
didn't own it the second thing that we
know is 100 of the time
over a 10-year period of time rents go
up
when you buy a condo at 150 and your
payment is 1100 bucks or whatever it is
your payment does not go up so what
you've done is the largest line item in
your budget is housing and you have
stabilized it into the future when you
buy you're locking it in into the future
when you buy by not locking it in you're
a hundred percent guaranteed your
largest line item is going to go up I
mean you're 42 think about when you were
32 what rent was
you know I'm 62. my rent when I was 22
was 235 dollars
for a one bedroom
that Sharon and I moved into after we
got married I mean that's hard to even
grasp in today you know 41 years later
right very very hard to even get my head
around that because you can't even walk
on the property now for 235 dollars I
mean it's just you know but but uh and
so you think about over the scope of my
life like 40 years where's your rank I
mean it's going to be 235 versus
1235 today and you know 100 of the time
that largest line item is going up when
you're a permanent renter so you are
always paying more and someone else is
benefiting from the increases in value
not you so short term I'm all about
renting when you're broke you should
rent until you get yourself straightened
out don't buy a house just because
buying a house is a good thing because
it's not a good thing when you're broke
but long-term home ownership stabilizes
your largest line item in your budget
locks in your monthly cost to a fixed
amount and you have this large asset
that is going up in value that's right
these are two wonderful personal
financial benefits to home ownership so
plan on in the next 12 to 18 months
finding you a little condo to buy
doesn't have to be anything fancy right
we're not asking to go crazy and you
don't have to mow grass I don't care you
know if I'm you I'm not mowing grass I'd
get a condo you know this it doesn't
matter if you have kids it doesn't have
no matter if you have a wife oh that
that all applies period future future
financial planning is important for
everybody it's really the moral of the
story yeah and if you buy a condo in
five years from now you your whole life
changes and you sell it you're gonna
make money on it yeah you know so just
pick a good one in a good neighborhood
something solid conservative and not
straining you and stabilize that line
item in your budget
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
our scripture of the day is proverbs 4
11. I have instructed you in the way of
wisdom I have led you in upright paths
Roy Disney said
it is not hard to make decisions when
you know what your values are
you know we've that's Walt's brother
we've said that around here in entree
leadership for years if you know once
you know what your value system is you
know what your core values are
a lot of your decisions are already made
for you in business that's right the
problem is that you have to do them then
and there's always conflict and people
that don't understand yeah and they
don't like it and there's a discomfort
and awkwardness and all of that but that
doesn't change the value yeah and it
doesn't change the decision it's just oh
crap now I've got to shovel the stable
yeah look there's just a bunch of manure
in here yeah yeah I just got to do it
now it's just yeah it's the same thing
when you commit to a plan though yeah
all your decisions are made for you if
you if you just decide to follow Christ
you follow the Bible all the decisions
are in there you just gotta follow it
same thing when you commit to a plan
like what we teach on here the decisions
are made it's just hard to do this stuff
yeah exactly Joe is with us in
Huntsville Hey Joe what's up
Joe um how's it going Dave better than I
deserve sir how can I help
uh same with me hey we're in uh me and
my I'm I'm 23 years old I'm in an
extremely unique position and we're
grateful uh I would just like to have
some advice for hey what's next I feel
like we're doing everything right but
you know just when you think you are you
um you know the good old Faith put you
back in check so
um like I said I'm 23 I am married I got
married at a young age uh and we are
doing really good for ourselves uh we we
have no debt whatsoever we both
graduated college with no debt we have
new cars uh we bought a house right
before covid
um and that has doubled in price and we
got such an interest rate on it we uh
turned it into a rental property so I'm
getting a hundred percent profit for
that for the rental house we're on our
second house right now
um I'm investing into a Roth IRA
I have emergency funds set up I mean and
I have 20 000 sitting in the bank and
it's continuing to grow because we have
a good job so what's next you know what
what is my next goal what's my next set
to I guess wealth building yeah well Joe
you are doing good I'm proud of you well
done what's your what's your household
income sir
uh together my wife and I make
um about a hundred a year and keep in
mind you know we're only 23 and she's a
teacher and she the second year teaching
and uh I own my my own company that's
extremely successful and doing very well
so we um this is just the beginning
levels and we can we're going to make a
whole lot more
um good okay
um what what I want to encourage you is
the uh you are doing very well uh
there's so much energy and so many
positive
um
adjectives in your description of your
situation that uh it makes me a little
bit fearful that you're going to try to
move too fast if you stumble it's not
going to be because of what you've done
so far it's going to be because you get
uh
a low cocky
and uh you know uh Jim Collins wrote a
book about companies failing and he said
one of the reasons they fail is hubris
which is I got arrogant and I'm not
saying you're arrogant Joe at all okay
but you are fired up and you are on top
of the world and you got the tiger by
the tail and you're smiling yeah
it's fun and so what I'm going to
encourage you as the old guy to do is
slow down a Beat
not stop being ambitious not stop
striving for success but just slow down
a beat when I was your age I started
buying and selling real estate I had
nothing
I went to the bank and borrowed the
money to do my first flip and
um I began flipping real estate to date
I'm now 62 uh getting ready to be 63
I've owned over 2 000 pieces of real
estate so I love real estate I love this
but what happened to me was I got rich
quick
by the time I was 26 I had a million
dollar net worth on four million dollars
worth of Real Estate
but I had borrowed up to my eyeballs I
had three million dollars worth of debt
the bank got sold to another bank they
called our notes we spent the next two
and a half years of our life losing
everything we owned and with a brand new
baby and a toddler we were bankrupt and
got to start over when I was 28. I don't
want that for you you're not as crazy as
I was a year and moved as fast as I
moved but you but but I'm just trying to
give you the warning to say okay let's
slow down a little bit you're going to
be a multi-millionaire Joe
when you're 40 your net worth is going
to be well over 5 million dollars okay
wow I can promise you that but I promise
you it won't be if you keep borrowing
money and buying real estate you're
going to get yourself in trouble
slow
down a notch next goal is pay off your
house the next goal is pay off your
rental and the next goal is pay cash for
the next investment property and you're
going to be debt free and pay cash for
things every day from that point forward
that's what Jade and I would tell you to
do
okay but right now it feels like right
now it feels like it's impossible for
you to mess this up it is not impossible
for you to mess this up you can mess
this up I did it with zeros on the end
can I ask you a question
what was your next group I'm just
curious your next move going to be
well I have um
because my father he has a lot of really
well connections and
um one of his good friends has hundreds
of kind of a mental places down in the
college town Auburn University so I'm
thinking I'm getting a lot of my advice
from a lot of wealthy people that I
currently know and he that this is
without my ambition to do it but uh my
next goal was to
um kind of every year for the next five
years by build a new house from scratch
um because you know you get all the
warranties and all the proceeds from
building new I mean and they're just
they're just this cheap building a new
thing if you buy them you know
Fixer-Upper so my ambition was to buy a
new house every year move into it for my
primary residence and then you know get
a conventional loan with a with a low
interest rate until they get lower
um again but kind of build a new one
each year and that when I move out of it
then I'll start renting that one and my
plan was to do that for the next five or
ten years so every year just building
new and move into it for a year and then
start to process over and then keep
renting so with what Dave said
that's the opposite of that or if you
did it you'd be paying cash yeah you'd
have to slow down a little bit and pay
cash for the get your house paid off get
the other one paid off and then pay cash
for the next move and if you start doing
that every time you do it you pay cash
for it I'm in yeah but like but that's
going to take you know you're gonna
you're gonna slow down you're gonna do
every other year at the most
to pull that off I thought about getting
the incomes from so if I have five
rentals I'll get those five extra
incomes and and pay off the lowest one
first and then once that 100 profit then
I start doing the next one and then the
next one
that is spoken like a naive landlord
okay so again I own several hundred
million dollars worth of real estate
more than your Dad's friend all things
have to go perfect for that to be the
case yeah and 100 of the time renters
don't pay
okay you just can count on it all right
it's part I mean most of them pay most
of them are good people you do a good
job screening they don't tear up stuff
they pay the bills everything's okay but
um this idea that you're making 100
profit is just false yeah because after
you pay after your vacancy after you
have credit loss after you have an
eviction after you have someone go into
chapter 13 and it takes 14 months to get
them evicted because you have to get the
federal court permission to do it you're
going to start understanding then that
renters really aren't you know this this
thing where you've got all this dialed
in it has to go perfect and it never
goes perfect for your plan to work
so I don't think I won here I think
you're going to do whatever you're going
to do yeah I think but um but I think
you're an impressive young guy and I
wish I could get you to slow down a
little bit because I think you'd have a
higher probability of ending up very
wealthy yeah uh than you would following
your dad's friend's process of going
deeply into debt if you want to do that
you probably need to follow my friend
Robert Kiyosaki he believes in borrowing
all you can borrow and um and he's made
a lot of money doing it uh he and our
friends we like each other but we
completely think the other one's nuts I
mean this guy is sprinting and when
you're sprinting it's a lot easier to
trip and fall as opposed to just a nice
light jog just just jog it out and for a
light jog you know
that's that's what yeah it's different
than the old Sprint yeah that puts us
out of the Ramsey Show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]